lo sbaglio
action the wait and see
no io verrei sono andate
anzi no nuke
wright vitali you're going for alessi 7
punti vice dai live live la può ma sono
ben fissi provati e riprovati in un
modello
la gente fa senza 100 cani una ci
mettessimo bot
ma come facebook
quanti slay cai a come salvare mi metto
in caldaia
ma quando sei qui
più
ne vedo
finita marche insomma
non avrebbe potuto essere lavato e più
avrebbe dimostrato che l'uomo il genere
umano
noi insomma eravamo potenzialmente
capaci di costruire una mole infinita di
dolore e che il dolore e la sola forza
che si crei dal nulla senza spesa e
senza fatica basta non vedere non
ascoltare non fare se comprendere è
impossibile conoscere è necessario
perché ciò che è accaduto può ritornare
le coscienze possono di nuovo essere
sedotte ed oscurate anche le nostre
oggi ho voluto iniziare con questo passo
di primo levi perché oggi è la giornata
mondiale del rifugiato per spiegarvi
come abbiamo creato il mons
dobbiamo ritornare all 8 luglio del 2013
quando io e mio marito christopher ci
trovavamo a lampedusa
anzi avevamo lasciato il porto di
lampedusa per andare in tunisia per
lavoro era una vacanza lavoro e noi
eravamo in mare
in questo tratto lampedusa tunisia
abbiamo guardato tra le onde galleggiava
una giacca era un segno tangibile delle
persone che oggi muoiono in mare
chiamati i migranti
questi numeri queste masse che vengono
spogliate dall'individualità e così è
molto facile trasformarli in fantasmi
beh noi non crediamo che queste persone
siano dei fantasmi e per questo abbiamo
voluto metterci in gioco
papà francesco da lampedusa ci lanciamo
un messaggio un messaggio di solidarietà
diceva che anzi vi leggo le sue frasi
abbiamo perso il senso della
responsabilità la sofferenza degli altri
quasi non ci interessa più non ci
riguarda non è affar nostro
però in ogni senso anche lui ci spronava
ci spronava ad andare avanti ci spronava
a metterci in gioco e quindi noi abbiamo
voluto abbattere il muro
dell'indifferenza
ma come farlo a parole no abbiamo voluto
farlo con i fatti e quindi siamo passati
da un idea ad una realtà e così è nato
il mons
nel 2013 ancora il mare nostrum non era
iniziato perché inizio dopo la tragedia
del 3 di ottobre e quindi molte o ng
operazioni umanitarie lavoravano a terra
non c'era nessuna che lavorava in mare
in mare proprio lì dove tutte queste
persone stavano morendo e quindi per
andare in mare avevamo bisogno di una
nave con mio marito abbiamo cercato una
nave la phoenix l'abbiamo trovata a
norfolk virginia la phoenix e un
vascello di 40 metri
l'abbiamo riadattato per il soccorso in
mare
l'abbiamo equipaggiato con non è l'i pad
con giubbotti di salvataggio life raft
dottor i paramedici coperte vestiti per
ridare umanità queste persone che quando
prendevamo in mare erano trattate peggio
delle bestie e così abbiamo deciso di
continuare e quando abbiamo deciso di
investire nella
tecnologia usando i droni parlando con
gli altri ci credevano dei folli dei
folli dei folli perché volevamo andare
ad aiutare in mare delle persone come
noi soltanto che queste persone hanno
pelle diversa beh noi l'abbiamo fatto e
abbiamo siamo usciti da queste bolle di
sapone che sono belle ma non sono nulla
e così nel 2014
abbiamo finanziato la nostra missione è
da ottobre a e scusate e da agosto ad
ottobre abbiamo salvato 3 mila persone
poi abbiamo lanciato
poi abbiamo lanciato il crowdfunding la
raccolta fondi per il 2015 perché non ce
la facevamo più non avevamo più i fondi
per continuare il 2 di maggio siamo
ripartiti a questi folli si sono
aggiunti msf medici senza frontiere la
delegazione di amsterdam e salite in
nave con noi ea oggi si sta occupando
del post rischio del posto soccorso
questa per noi è stata una soddisfazione
grandissima ma come lo è ogni volta che
noi portiamo queste persone in mare e
vorrei parlarvi di una storia che
mi ha colpito tantissimo e mi sta molto
a cuore
se mandatele immagine rigoni e della sua
mamma per favore questa è la storia di
un bambino e salire in a very notte la
sua mamma ce lo ha portato in braccio
dicendo self help aiutami subito con il
dottore l'abbiamo portato in clinica
noi non sapevamo non capivamo se questo
bambino fosse morto perché non
rispondeva poi il dottore ha controllato
aveva la febbre altissima così
dopo diverse ore lui si è ripreso io non
riuscivo come donna come madre non
riuscivo a togliere lo sguardo dalla
della mamma i suoi occhi erano disperati
e una madre che poteva perdere il
proprio figlio perché non ci stavo una
medicina un antibiotico una tachipirina
che poteva salvargli la vita un qualcosa
di così semplice che noi abbiamo nel
cassetto della cucina loro non lo
avevano poi ogni si è ripreso e adesso
lo vedete come gioca con la sua mamma
e i suoi amichetti sulla nave che
abbiamo dato dei vestitini un giocattolo
lui è un bimbo di tre anni che colpa se
in eritrea ci sta alla guerra se in
siria non non si può più stare
che colpa ne ha adesso noi siamo
rientrati sono ho fatto parte di diverse
missioni però ci sta una bambina che mi
ha veramente emozionato e lei è scesa
qualche settimana fa l'abbiamo sbarcata
da augusta e lei mi ha dato la forza di
scrivere questi passi che vorrei
dividere con voi e concludere quella mia
questa sera si chiama a milioni milioni
milioni di occhi milioni di mani milioni
di bimbi milioni di madri e milioni di
padri che prezzo non hanno ma un prezzo
hanno pagato e di loro tutto è stato
violato arrivare in europa o morire lo
sanno non c'è alternativa
non c'è umanità la casa mia brucia la
finestra e di là
questa è la mia unica possibilità
soffrire provando o morire restando
pregando sperando che arrivi in europa
la terra di pace che guerra non ha
milioni hanno pagato milioni milioni di
corpi raccolti nel mare milioni di
storie milioni di vite salvate e
sommerse l'amore che vince il credo che
spinge ad andare per mare a cercare la
gente che fugge da dove più pace non v'è
ciao